to go into the school boys and women of
course sorry
come on main left side baby left side is
the oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up
for goddamn best game best game don't
worry about it
don't don't worry about a man it's gonna
be okay okay it's fine
it's gonna be an AR right here oh okay
you know what
I'll think it to one simple how you
doing baby
oh there Redis innocent orange pepper
well I feel bad
oh boy my favorite okay be good
what is happening you
come out and play please do it okay [ __ ]
it first drop
got a car anyway I don't need you guys
all right let's go
[Music]
I think I know a good spot don't worry
about a fam
got another car
that's [ __ ] sound
it's a drop what do you got family
let's go baby I need some action in this
game place
don't flip
jared is very nice
yeah sorry
good luck
all right I'm going straight for it cuz
[ __ ] it
sure this gonna go great it's hey [ __ ]
yes they're worth taking that give me
back my [ __ ] then
all right off yeah uh how am i alive uh
yes go go go yeah yeah that looks like a
penis that was [ __ ] MLG as [ __ ] boy
you see that you see how fast I did that
ain't no [ __ ] ain't nobody as fast as me
boy
let me reload this [ __ ] eight
times on this baby
yep
I'm gonna switch calm down all right let
me just let me just rethink my
strategies in here it's it's not camping
it's [ __ ] sake this [ __ ] fence
[ __ ] you fence yeah that's right suck it
yeah okay yes all right what did we got
red dot on you baby uh-huh
no yes I'm gonna snipe with the a kay
there we go
waterfall where did we got come up come
up
I pray [ __ ] you
we're going there no here well that was
exciting wow what a great game just
where I left her baby don't worry Pam I
know a great spot alright
Shh did that on purpose a lot of people
don't know how to do that on purpose but
I definitely know a thing or two about
doing those on purpose what the [ __ ] put
a tent there god damn homeless people
perfect parking all right so now in here
I'm we're gonna do some philosophy okay
not camping we're just thinking about
things anyone here
it's clear baby oh that was close
[Music]
calm down homeless people I knew it all
right baby [ __ ]
thank you Jesus
come on thank you
this is getting exciting
let's loot the homeless guy who knows he
might be rich
[ __ ] did he go or was he
I swear he was here what da [ __ ] VAT did
he go
[ __ ] gonna have to use the penis never
thought I'd say that on ironically
[ __ ] this makes me anxious I have no
idea where anyone is
I don't like that huh okay
a little further this is my tree okay
I'm naming you tennis thank you alright
where's this [ __ ] guy
ah headshot keep forgetting to [ __ ]
bullet drop Jesus Oh
oh [ __ ]
get him it's pretty pointless but hey oh
that [ __ ] fence are you kidding me
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] seriously
this game man
it's rope gonna ask game everyone knows
that refresh offends will [ __ ] you up
boy I've no idea where anyone
had to leave tennis and all [ __ ] that
here we go I'm in the circle I don't see
anyone you can never trust grass in this
game
silence I think he's there [ __ ]
that's fine I'm in the circle doesn't
matter Jesus that's the silence guy what
the [ __ ]
come on main I'm all hyped up for your
baby
[ __ ] drop shot of that dude should
take its ghillie suit it's too late now
I mean oh there is win great G says
great I just threw the [ __ ] game
jesus [ __ ] christ
there you go
he's got to walk to me
what the [ __ ] where do you come from how
the [ __ ] did he get there why did I not
shoot him it's fine it's fine it's fine
I got nades it's fine look at that still
in it baby it's done [ __ ] oh no I can't
see anything
it's headshot time come on baby
,
boy that's cuz I respect women G oh no
camping whatsoever thank you shut up AG
shut up to be honest I probably should
have died a couple times there but hey I
did oh man uh it feels so [ __ ] good
it makes MA it makes things to my body
that I don't even want to describe cuz
this video will get demonetised lah
thank you for all their support on these
videos it's super fun I love playing
this game and [ __ ] yeah that feels good
[ __ ] yeah boy what leave a like if you
like for tennis